[Music]
so hello I'm Jeff Allen I'm a cloud
solutions architect from Google cloud
and I'm here also with Rick Dellinger
and rich Meester's from Citrix and
they're gonna be joining us as we get
into this presentation
this is cmp 206 journey to the cloud
confidently with Citrix and Google cloud
what we're gonna kind of talk about
today one is a demo of our open source
project that helps you build Citrix
environments on GCP we're also going to
talk about the Citrix workspace vision
talk about the architectural components
of Citrix on GCP and walk through a
number of architectures including a
reference architecture as well as some
examples that we've worked on with
customers so let's dig right into this
we're starting with a demo which I think
it breaks some rules and breakout
sessions that you start with a demo but
the reason that we're doing this is we
want to show really how quickly and
easily you can set up Citrix on GCP
leveraging the open source project we
have out on github and so if we start
the scripts at the beginning we'll be
able to come back by the end of the
presentation actually explore this
environment that we've built in the
course of a breakout session so we're
gonna start by looking at this github
project we have it's based on the
deployment guide that Citrix
authored in 2017 released a sort of
reference architecture for how to build
Citrix environments on GCP and we wanted
to make it easy to walk through an
automated process to build those
environments so we used deployment
manager PowerShell scripts to bootstrap
the instances so you can basically take
that environment that's described in
that document and build it by just
kicking off a script from github all you
have to do is clone the github
repository Citrix on GCP run a script
deploy dot ps1 that kicks off the
deployment manager and then come back to
it currently the latest version of this
takes about 22 minutes to deploy an
environment and
and you've got a working environment to
explore it sets a notepad is a sample
virtual app but we have a branch that
shows you in the project how to
customize that if you want to set up
additional apps in your in your Citrix
on GCP environment and then once it's
built you use the Citrix workspace to
access those virtual apps and we also
have a script in there to resize to the
fleet does some rudimentary fleet
management initially it builds the
virtual fleet with just one instance but
you can run this resize script if you
want to add additional capacity so maybe
you're doing a demo it gets popular you
need some additional capacity for
virtual sessions you can run that resize
script to have a larger fleet of workers
and there's a clean up script that you
can run at the end which tears down all
of the GCP resources and it also cleans
up the Citrix cloud resources because
this bootstraps not only the Google
environment but also the Citrix
environment and this cleanup script will
tear down both of the environments so it
doesn't leave you with any stranded
objects doesn't leave you with any
billing once you're done with the once
you're done with the demo now what we're
gonna if you'll switch to the laptop
what we're gonna look at today is
actually not in the master branch of our
github repository it's in a branch
called experimental which you're welcome
to check out we've been working on
improving the speed of the build and
also reworking the architecture a bit to
take advantage of some of the newer
managed resources like when the initial
architecture came out GCP didn't have a
managed cloud NAT we do now NAT as a
service and so we've been reworking the
architecture to take advantage of those
newer services so this experimental
branch is sort of the leading edge of
where this project is and its deploys
faster and actually more simply
leveraging this managed services so
let's take a look this is the Google
cloud platform console obviously we're
gonna hop into your cloud shell and
I have hopefully we're having a job okay
so I have this checked out already so
we're gonna go to github Google cloud
platform citrix on GCP and i'll do a git
status will just see that i'm up to date
with the experimental branch now there's
still a deployed up ps1 script i'm
hopping into powershell by the way if
you're interested in running powershell
and cloud shell hit me up and i'll show
you how to how to set that up but all
you have to do to set this up is run
deployed up ps1 and then give it some
you know parameters like what domain
this sets up active directory as part of
the environment that it bootstraps
active directory along with all the
citrix configuration so it's gonna set
up an Active Directory domain we're
gonna say domain say example org give it
an that bias name we're gonna tell it
I'm gonna give it a flag called use
minimal resources one of the nice things
about this project is that you can use
trial accounts both for Google and for
Citrix so you can run this actually you
know for free and use minimal resources
is like a small footprint version that
works within the free tier limitations
I'm gonna tell it a region let's use us
West one and this is new in the
experimental branch I'm going to tell it
citrix creds for credentials path this
is a adjacent file it's described in the
readme but it's a JSON file that has the
Citrix client API credentials so that it
can connect with the Citrix API and
bootstrap the Citrix cloud environment
and so I've created a JSON file and have
these loaded in Google Cloud storage and
so basically this is all that you need
to do to build a Citrix environment on
GCP we'll kick this off and something's
wrong
it's citrus creds URL
there we go and so we'll see that it's
going to initialize a few things and
then very quickly go into deployment
manager where deployment manager is
gonna recognize that there's a
deployment that's been kicked off it's
an asynchronous operation it's gonna
stand up some instances bootstrap those
instances put a pin in this we'll come
back to it towards the end of our
presentation take a look at what it just
built and actually access that
environment run the virtual app and see
how that works so now I'm going to if
we'll go back to the slides I'm going to
turn the floor over to Rick Dellinger
who's going to share with us about the
Citrix workspace vision way thank you
Jeff what'd you think of the interesting
start kicking off a demo right at the
beginning of a session a little
interesting a little bit of a twist and
perhaps a little cart before the horse
so I'd actually like to start my section
here with a couple of questions for you
so for starters how many of you have
heard of or used Citrix technologies
before I see a pretty fair amount of
hands all right then how many of you
have been Citrix customers use this
stuff in production for five years
all right I'm gonna call that probably
30% maybe somewhere along those lines
all right so I'd wanted to ask that
question to kind of set the stage a
little bit because as I mentioned we in
some regards put the cart before the
horse a little bit because if some of
you have not heard of Citrix before you
may not have the faintest clue what it
was that we were actually showing you
there so I'm gonna take some time here
in this section to go ahead and
illustrate a few things for you so for
starters if we take a look at Citrix as
a company we're actually not unlike a
lot of you I would imagine in that we've
been enterprise an enterprise
organization that's been around for a
long time has a lot of history and a lot
of infrastructure of our own history of
products and acquisitions that we've
been dealing with over time but we're
founded around this idea of taking
originally the OS two operating system
get into a multi-user operating system
which it wasn't at the time and allowing
people to connect into that remotely so
that whole concept of taking platforms
and making them kind of mainframe like
if you will giving you the ability to
connect to him remotely is kind of where
the organization started and that goes
back into 1991 was about the time that
the first product was launched and over
time Citrix has evolved substantially so
we're all about remote access for many
many many years and somewhere around the
2006 timeframe and actually backing it
up so remote access primarily to Windows
applications that's really where the
bulk of the growth in our organization
or our business came from so it's around
2006 that we actually introduced some
best-of-breed networking technologies
and our application delivery controllers
and then moving forward you see a bit
more of the transition that we've made
across time and I'm not going to touch
on all of these in the instance of time
but kind of the place that we've landed
ultimately and we're still at today
we've got this this capability or this
vision of the citrix secure workspace
that I'm going to chat with you a little
bit about today so one common theme here
is that with all the different spaces
that we've been as we been evolving
dramatically alongside the IT industry
over time one thing that's been kind of
a common thread of what we've been doing
is that we've always been trying to lead
the future of work so let me let me
describe that a little bit more so at
Citrix we fundamentally believe that
work is something that you do not
someplace that you go and today's
technologies actually make that a lot
more feasible than they did and you know
roll back even five years ten years
darah even go back 15 years and in our
in our current version in the way that
we're building and bringing a product to
market we put people in security at the
center of everything it is that we do so
if you think about any
any given knowledge worker the next
generation the cloud workers that are
coming into the workforce today or the
way that a lot of our knowledge workers
are transitioning into more like cloud
workers where they're innovating versus
just going along with business as usual
one common scenario that you see is that
the users tend to be roaming around
accessing accessing or needing to access
their corporate applications and data
from a variety of different devices in a
variety of different locations now those
resources they may be accessing could be
stored anywhere today right they could
be in the cloud they could be in an
on-premises or customer managed type of
a data center or they could be
applications or services that you're
consuming from the public cloud but the
key here is that we put the user in the
middle of that now kind of stepping
forward into the Citrix of today so
we're not they're not the smallest
organization we've been around for quite
a few years right since the the 89
timeframe so what we're all about today
is this whole concept of the intelligent
workspace and the intelligent workspace
is really there are a lot of parallels
if you know and understand the Google
cloud worker vision and the direction
that Google is taking it with the
combination of things like chrome and
Chrome enterprise and the G suite
applications and I ap and a lot of the
different services that are available on
GCP our intelligent workspace vision and
the products that we're developing and
bringing to market today to help make
that happen are all about bringing
together the apps and information and
services that the users need to do their
job and to innovate bringing those to
any device that they may have available
to them at any point in time over any
type of a network that they've got and
so this vision of the intelligent
workspace we we assume make the
assumption that the the user is going to
need to be able to access those
resources wherever they happen to be
right so we take the perimeter that used
to be the corporate firewall at your
primary data center for
organization we're essentially moving
that perimeter instead of being at the
edge of a business or a data center
we're moving that perimeter out around
the actual user itself so Citrix of
today we count over 400,000 customers
those are customers as in businesses we
don't really have any consumer facing
technologies in the market today we've
got coverage through a large percentage
of the fortune 500 and ultimately we got
over a hundred million licensed users
out in the market space so we've grown a
heck of a lot and along the way you know
as I mentioned we did historically
probably very similar to you had been
building services and building products
that we've been shipping kind of
traditionally right so fall on the old
traditional waterfall model building
packaged products that we would then
test and put in a box and actually sit
people a box so over time we've been on
a pretty substantial digital
transformation of our own moving our own
business away from that model of
delivering perpetual products and moving
into the delivery of those technologies
via services so you'll hear us talk
about this thing called Citrix Cloud
today and I want to ensure you that this
is not an is you're not going to go buy
some some compute and some networking
and some storage from us so Citrix cloud
is is our platform that we leverage to
deliver all these innovative services to
our customers so this platform is
cloud-based we're doing all the similar
types of things with rapid iteration and
release cycles and Canaria of releases
and all those kinds of things that
you're probably also dealing with but
with this cloud-based platform we're pre
integrating the services so you can
consume multiple different services on
their own to solve point problems or you
can consume multiple services together
and the platform itself integrates those
services and saves you from a lot of the
work then we're also with the platform
managing and maintaining and upgrading
keeping evergreen all the components
that go into the solution but one point
I make here is that Citrix has a lot
experience from
our digital transformation one kind of
unique thing that we've been doing is
taking those experiences and our lessons
learned and rolling those into features
and capabilities of our cloud platform
so one of the thing that we pride
ourselves on is providing apps and
services via Citrix cloud that help our
enterprise customers with their digital
transformation journeys right meet them
on their way on their journey and help
add some value and help them get more of
the value out of digital transformation
so I'm not going to touch on all these
points here but I just want to point out
a couple key things for starters you've
recognized that date of 2011 that was
the launch of Chrome in the Chrome OS
and Chromebooks right so Citrix was
actually one of the the launch partners
one of the the key partners so we
brought at the time it was our Citrix
Receiver we brought to market and that
allowed organizations to adopt
Chromebooks for their end user access
and it gave the business and IT a way to
deliver their Column legacy today
applications like Windows applications
on Linux based applications deliver
those down to of Chromebooks so we've
seen a lot of success and if you look
over the years the main thing I want you
to pick out from this is the velocity of
innovation so especially as you get into
the last three years you'll see that the
velocity of innovation and the
co-investment on both sides of this
Alliance has been substantial and you're
going to continue to see a lot more of
that evolve as time goes so very quickly
the ecosystem of solutions that we
provide here kind of the center if you
will of the user experience is this
thing called the Citrix workspace the
workspace platform it's accessed through
this thing called the Citrix workspace
app which is either a web browser or
it's a native app across all different
types of platforms and it's kind of that
common consumption point or aggregation
point of those virtualized Windows apps
as being one of the types of services
but we're also delivering things like
SAS based applications doing single
sign-on to those things wrapping a bunch
of advanced analytics and
dirty services around those and here
very recently well very recently being
the last year and a half or so we've
also substantially stepped up the
capabilities to deploy virtualized apps
and desktops on GCP so pulling this back
around to that demo that we started with
so that demo that we started with was
showing you an automated very simple way
to get started deploying virtualized
applications and desktops on GCP the key
point I want to make there is that
Citrix is not just about virtualized
apps and desktops we still do that a lot
however we've got a lot more services
and capabilities available in the
marketplace today
so the solution areas that you'll find
us working together on you can see kind
of a quick snapshot of here so in the
productivity and workspace area if
you're using G suite and the workspace
app we provide our content collaboration
capabilities that snap into G suite in
the workspace we provide this advanced
access control that if you want to you
can come check out the booth and we'll
show you off some of that stuff on the
far right you're talking about our
endpoint management capabilities which
are built into Citrix cloud and and
those integrate and work very well with
both Chrome Enterprise and with Android
Enterprise Android for work and then
finally if you're you're in the GCP
world if that's kind of where your
technology focus is and where we're
gonna spend the bulk of the rest of our
time here in this session then you're
leveraging GCP to deploy our virtual
apps and desktops also some of our
networking technologies and appliances
and that's the area that we're gonna be
focusing on for the rest of the
afternoon session so at this point I'm
going to turn things over to my
colleague here rich Meester's to take us
through a little bit more depth take us
away Jay thanks Rick watch where the mic
goes I guess so
what I want to do is delve a little bit
further down into the architectural
components of Citrix virtual apps and
desktops on GCP we did talk about you
know Rick has gone through what
cloud was what the workspace is really
it's a bunch of services cloud delivered
services that wrap around this whole
workspace experience a lot of these will
come into play in that Citrix Google
ecosystem in terms of delivering an
overall service to your customers but
what we want to focus on is really those
items that we're dealing with in the
demo and fundamentally they're what
we're looking at is you know what Jeff
started building at the beginning of the
session and the focus of the components
that we're putting on Google cloud is
really the virtual apps and desktop
services and then we're going to back in
we're going to front-end that with the
workspace and the workspace experience
from an end-user experience perspective
coming off the Chromebook so what is the
Citrix virtual apps and desktop services
I think Rick you know kind of covered it
it's really the foundation of what we've
been doing at Citrix for the last
approximately thirty years and that is
deploying Windows workloads and now
Linux workloads in a centralized
location whether that's on a customer
premise or in a public cloud like GCP
and then allowing users to access those
applications in a secure fashion so the
Citrix apps and virtual Citrix virtual
apps and desktop service itself is
really the cloud hosted control plane
and that's Citrix Spanish components so
that's the glue that holds all of the
infrastructure together as well as
workloads that our customers put in
their data centers wherever they may
want to put them so in their data
centers in public cloud pretty much
wherever they want to put them and then
the users access those applications
using the workspace app anywhere anytime
from any device that they want to access
them from the key components here that
will start to kind of break down and
talk about the Citrix connectors they're
the component that provide that link
between customers GCP resource location
and the Citrix Cloud control plane as
well as the VDS which is the agent
or what we call a virtual delivery agent
that we install on the virtual desktops
or the Windows server the Linux server
to provide access to the applications on
them so in terms of what components we
actually require our minimal set is we
need a couple of Citrix Cloud connectors
and those are Windows server instances
and the virtual delivery agents so those
agents running on there it's Windows or
Linux instances to deliver the
applications other components that we
require Active Directory is required for
a citrix system all of our Windows
machines are domain joined and so you
absolutely have to have Active Directory
in your environment but in many
customers situations from a security
perspective they don't at least
initially want to put Active Directory
controllers into a public cloud
infrastructure so really what we need is
we need the service other optional
components that we have within the
environment we have SMB file shares for
Windows user profiles we have our Citrix
ADCs or gateways and those are we'll
talk a little bit more about what the
ADC does but it's part of our access to
your infrastructure as well as
storefront we've talked about the
workspace and workspace experience some
customers opt to go with our older
version of that which is storefront and
then they can build that it within their
own infrastructure and control the
routing of their traffic through those
infrastructures and finally federated
authentication and certificate services
are components that allow us to
federates amal based authentication into
our Active Directory components so these
are other additional components that
we'll talk a little bit about as we go
through the reference architectures so
the cloud connectors as we said they
really provide that glue or that layer
in between the customers environment and
the Citrix managed control plane and
they're there to provide services to
support the connection between those two
components we do say we want to have two
can
in every resource location that we have
these connectors are citrix managed in
components so we we will reach down to
those components or when they reach up
to us we'll check their version and we
will update them periodically so we want
to have a minimum of two of those in any
resource location so we maintain high
availability we also want to put these
resources connectors in different
availability zones within GCP so that we
can tolerate again we get higher levels
of availability and tolerate failures
potential failures within a zone within
that component there's multiple services
that are running the secure ticket
authority is used by the Gateway to
ensure that communications are secure
between the front end user and user end
and the back end gateway services if
we're using the Gateway in the cloud
provides that path for the the traffic
from the workload to the users endpoint
to transit brokering is is it's kind of
its primary function is just to make
sure that users are getting access to
the resources they need as well as
provisioning services and we'll talk a
little bit about machine creation
services later which allow us to do
single instance management and managing
the identity so Citrix does not maintain
the customers Active Directory in our
control plane customer maintains that on
their own resource location and the
identity the identity service within the
connection within the connector will
manage that typically what we see with
these are usually four V CPUs and 12 to
16 gigabytes of RAM and the
communication from the connector is a
TLS 1.2 outbound only connection to the
citrus control plane the Windows virtual
delivery agent this is the component
that sits on top of the workloads and it
connects the Windows and Linux instances
to the virtual apps and desktop service
it's a software package that's installed
on that server or desktop instance and
it basically communicates with the
connectors on TCP port 80 to register
itself with the system and also
communique
out to the end-users outbound with TCP
1494 2598 natively and often that is
done through a gateway service where
that is that then encapsulated in 443
now one of the important points when
you're looking at your infrastructure is
the scalability most of your
infrastructure that you build in a
Citrix environment is going to be work
load we have a few connector servers
will have some storefront potentially
some federated authentication services
but you're really only talking about a
handful of servers servers at that point
so your majority is going to be either
virtual desktops or Windows servers that
are publishing apps and because of that
scalability of these plays a major part
in looking at your design for VDI it's
really simple it's you know kind of
picking out the best instance type that
you might have for your workload for
server based computing then we want to
start want to look at single instance
scalability within GCP to understand how
many users can we get on a given
workload and Citrix did last year or
some baseline scalability testing we use
log in vs I and we work through several
iterations of various instance types in
GCP and what we found at that time was
the best instance type that we had our
instance size that we had was the n1
standard 8 4 for the workloads for Xen
app workloads for server based computing
workloads and we ran about 33 users per
VM on that given using a standardized
knowledge worker workload in in log n
BSI other considerations here you want
to look at optimizing your cost through
discounts so of course if you're
familiar with GCP you know that by
default something the GCP has that other
cloud providers don't have or the
sustained use discounts so taking a look
at how you discount your environment
based on VMs running over a period of
time and there's a good amount of detail
here that I'm not going to go into but
also the committed use discount which is
more I guess a traditional discounting
you'll see across cloud providers where
you have 1 and 3-year commitments where
you pay a certain amount and
you run those workloads 100% of the time
certainly for some of the control
element workloads that you may put in
your in your resource location this is a
really good idea to take a look at
because you know they're going to be
running a hundred percent of the time
but we also want to take a look at it
from a perspective of what does it mean
for running workloads and Jeff was good
enough to put this graph together for us
as we did some of our architecture
discussions to kind of take a look at
the break points here for sustain and
committed use discounts so the green is
the standard sustained use and how it
increases over time the blue curve is a
three-year committed use and the purple
curve is a one-year committed use so
what you see here where those lines
intersect is really the point at which
it starts to make sense to consider
those committed use discounts for your
workloads for instance here if you're 50
percent of your workload is going to be
running a hundred percent of the time if
you're running sorry if you're running
your workload for 50 percent of the time
over a good over a month then you want
to start to consider looking at
committed use discounts the other thing
to consider for those workloads that
aren't going to be using committed use
is our Auto scale technology and this is
a technology that Citrix has developed
within the product that allows us to
take our workloads and dynamically power
manage them based on schedule and load
so we can define within our
configurations within Citrix when users
when session when machines should be
started up based on a schedule so Monday
to Friday 8:00 to 5:00 you should have X
number of machines running overnight you
should have X minus 5 on weekends you
should X minus 10 and we can also then
bundle that in with load based for our
server based computing and saying when
our load exceeds a certain point that
I'm going to start to scale up
additional machines finally the citrix
ADC on GC p so this is our application
delivery controller and that is our what
we used to call net scalar names have
changed recently
the functionality that we have in that
we're primarily looking at when we're
doing citrix on GCP are using it as an
ICA proxy gateway as opposed to using
the Gateway services and that's when
customers want to bring their own
routing into the into place so they
don't want to wrote through the internet
they want to route in and out of their
GCP resource locations individually to
control traffic as well as load
balancing for components if we put
storefront in place for instance and
potentially content switching as well we
do support single and multi knit
configurations in that so we can define
our topology from a network perspective
and understand how our how our
communications are going to happen with
intervene it's and we can deploy it
today as standalone instances they're
not yet available in in the in the store
right so we have them as a download and
then there's a step by step deployment
the URL here as well as some deployment
manager scripts to to get those going on
the horizon what we're looking at really
these are things that we're looking at
coming out with this year and into into
next year machine creation services and
that allows us to right now we can power
management within GCP but what we want
to do is get into being able to have a
single instance management across a
number of machines so we can manage a
single OS application package and then
deploy to multiple machines having
native Google ID support in excuse me in
Citrix workspace so rather than having
to log on with Active Directory
credentials being able to log on
directly with your Google ID as well as
sd1 on GCP and there was an announcement
today about that SD when on GCP will be
available within the store coming up in
one month and Sdn is used to for
software-defined networking and setting
up paths between branches and data
centers having multiple redundant paths
and logic and how you switch between
them and as well on the ADC side we have
some enhancements coming up primarily
around h.a having multiple ABCs and
having being able to manage them as well
as again integrating those into the
marketplace so with that let me turn it
back over to Jeff and we'll do a
walk-through of the reference
architecture thanks rich so what we're
gonna do take these pieces of the
architecture that rich just told us
about the cloud connectors the the BDA
etc and we're gonna explore basically
this is kind of a simple reference
architecture similar it's actually
what's being built by the by the scripts
and we're gonna look at a couple of
workflows to explore what each
architectural component is doing in in
those workflows so the first one we're
gonna look at is what happens when a
user logs in to the Citrix workspace so
it starts on the user's device whether
it's a laptop tablet phone whatever for
whatever operating system there are
native Citrix workspace apps there's
also an html5 workspace app that you can
access in the browser and so the user
will access the the Citrix workspace and
login now that login request goes up to
Citrix Cloud such as cloud doesn't
authenticate the user directly Citrix
cloud actually delegates that
authentication to the active directory
that's installed in the GCP environment
and so it does that by communicating
with those cloud connectors right it
passes along that authentication request
through the cloud connectors which
actually then authenticate the user
against the Active Directory domain
controllers those Active Directory
domain controllers may be standalone
domain controllers like they are in the
demo environment that our scripts are
building but more often than not it's
it's some kind of a you know maybe a
replication scenario where an on-prem
Active Directory is being replicated
into the cloud or there's some kind of
trust relationship set up there but once
those domain controllers authenticate
the user they'll pass back through the
cloud connector the authentication
results since your cloud will didn't say
ok I know who this user is now Citrix
Cloud makes an authorization decision
what does that user have access to
that's part of the control plane
functionality that exists in Citrix
cloud so it'll decide what virtual apps
what virtual desktops does that user
have access to
and then it will render in the workspace
you know a menu that allows the user to
choose from one of the apps or desktops
that they have access to so then the
next workflow we want to look at is what
happens in when a user chooses a virtual
app and how does that app get launched
and how does that'll work so again we're
starting here the users of the munis a
click on notepad I want to I want to run
notepad and as a virtual app so that
request will go up through six cloud and
Citrix cloud is going to then make a
decision there's a load balancing
decision here because you know this is a
fleet of servers being used by a group
of users and we have to allocate a
session on one of those servers these
are the VDA so we have to make an
allocation decision this is a session
brokering and management capabilities of
citrus cloud so it'll say ok well this
notepad session I'm gonna allocate that
on one of my available video servers now
it's going to pass that session
initialization information into the VDA
again through the cloud connectors and
then the cloud connector will pass that
along to the VDA the VDA will actually
did log in as the user launched notepad
and then initialize that user's virtual
appt session this is that I see a
traffic which talked about I see a
proxies now by default that I see a
traffic is going to stream from the VDA
server directly to Citrix cloud if
there's connectivity between the VDA at
Citrix Cloud it's going to go through
the Gateway service of citrus cloud and
then back to the end-user device now if
it can't
if the VDA can't communicate directly
with citrus cloud it'll it'll proxy that
traffic through the cloud connectors so
there's some path decisions being made
here but assuming that the VDA can
communicate with citrus cloud it's going
to stream that ica traffic through the
gateway service of Citrix cloud and then
back to that end user who then is going
to see notepad running on their device
and that's basically what will demo at
the end of the session
now that was a quick walkthrough sort of
a reference architecture and now Rick is
going to join me and we're gonna
actually walk through a couple of
real-world architectures maybe how we
adapted them how they're a little bit
similar to but in some ways different
than the reference architecture we just
looked at yeah so one thing that you'll
find about Citrix technologies and about
Citrix cloud is that their cloud
services right so there's a lot of
flexibility in what you consume how you
want to consume it we've we can leverage
technologies to tie the services
together from an automation standpoint
build those services so you actually
have a lot of flexibility in what you
can do what you can actually build with
it so I'll give you a little bit of a
pitch to come down and check out the
booth later on because we've got a
couple of interesting use cases we built
there so we wanted to share with you to
start off with this first customer I'm
not going to dive too deeply into it
because we've actually got a public case
study that'll be out there very very
shortly on this this this case study is
very representative of a lot of
traditional Citrix customers so they've
been a Citrix customer for some time and
they're facing a lot of the similar type
of IT challenges that you may be facing
as you're making your transition to the
cloud at your organization so they'd had
Citrix in place for a long time they've
they're been forced to deal with and
come up with ways that they can consume
cloud-based services to make them more
efficient more agile as an IT team and
they're also under some pressure to
reduce the costs of running their own
data centers so if they made some
decisions to move some of their
workloads up into the cloud in the
process they decided to start to consume
our cloud delivered services and
ultimately what they've ended up getting
out of this is a system that's much more
functional than what they've got there
they're able now to deliver SAS based
apps and mobile apps and such alongside
their windows-based apps
they've got consumption based pricing of
the infrastructure and they're
offloading a lot of the management
efforts both
to Citrix and on to Google which allows
them to deliver better services more
quickly so I'll leave it on that and
then I want to touch on one here that I
don't have a customer name to share for
you here but this use case is a little
bit different in that one it's education
but I think you'll see some relative
parallels here so in this case we've had
a system that had been teaching their
their students heavy weight applications
like CAD like the AutoCAD suite and the
way they've been doing that
traditionally is by investing in these
big monstrous workstations and they put
these workstations on to these mobile
carts that they would roll around room
to room and then as they would have X
number of students they'd roll the carts
into a room fire those things up and do
their thing well half the time those
things ended up just sitting there doing
nothing when they're not in class and
they paid for them all up front then of
course over time those things become
antiquated and need to be replaced
which is was the the driving force
behind this engagement with us so what
they ultimately ended up doing was
leveraging GCP our Citrix virtual apps
and desktops and also leveraging
invidious GPU instances that you can run
out on GCP so they're now running these
apps out of a GCP location near they're
paying for AutoCAD
actually not AutoCAD they own AutoCAD
but they're paying for their consumption
of both GPU and compute based on usage
so it ends up being substantially less
expensive for them and they're now able
to logistically just have the students
use whatever device they happen to bring
in and run those things so real quickly
so I leave some room for for Jeff here
the architecture that was deployed for
these guys actually was very similar to
the one that you see popping out the
back end of this automation tooling so
it was all very similar the one
difference from the reference
architecture that jeff shared with you
earlier is that the instances instead of
just being the general-purpose instances
they're actually instances with nvidia
GPU
Jews and their virtual data video us I
always stumble on what that acronym
stands for but they're basically
gpu-accelerated
instances that run up in side of Citrix
client excuse me
GC P they're also leveraging Citrix
gateways at the perimeter of GC P and
the reason they did that is because they
wanted to have the absolute best
possible performance so they got their
users closest to the nearest GC p region
they've got their gateways there as well
so they've got the utmost of performance
of the pipe the lowest possible latency
and they've also got the fullest
featured protocol stack in the midst of
it so with that I'm gonna go ahead and
hand over to this last one so this
customer this next customer it was a
public sector organization with a
mission-critical multi-tier app some of
the challenges that they had a heavy
database inter inter um interactions
they're trying to move to the cloud but
they're having trouble because if they
moved the application away from the
database they were getting great
performance they have a distributed
workforce so around the country they all
needed to access this application and
they weren't getting consistent you know
performance and they'd also invested in
an on-prem multi-factor authentication
scheme using smart cards and they needed
even in the cloud they needed to
authenticate their users against this
smart card infrastructure so the
solution was to move the application and
the database into Google Cloud so that
the chatty application was close to the
database in Google Cloud leveraging the
Google global network for distributing
this application using Citrix of virtual
apps to their distributed workforce and
the unique thing about our configuration
was that we set up federated
authentication against that on-prem
identity provider so they could leverage
their existing and infrastructure to
authenticate users so again it's similar
to the architecture we already looked at
a couple of differences one you'll
notice that the client device
don't initially talk to the citrus cloud
when they authenticate users now they're
configured the gateway is actually
running on an appliance in GCP and this
gives you a lot more flexibility to how
you configure that appliance here it's
then authenticated it's configured not
to authenticate against a local Active
Directory domain controller but instead
using sam'l to use that on-prem identity
provider which allowed this customer to
leverage the smart cards to the other
authentication and then you know once
the users are authenticated then the
workflow is similar to what we what we
looked at earlier alright so we've got a
few minutes left let's hop back to our
laptop and take a look at our demo
environment see if it builds happily and
if we have something that we can take a
look at so they deployed four instances
the cloud connector the CC is a cloud
connector we've been talking about the
DC is a domain controller and Active
Directory domain controller the third
one which is shut down now we called it
management it really was just a script
runner it ran the scripts that actually
configured Citrix Cloud right so once it
was done there was nothing else to do so
it shuts itself down the way we've set
up this deployment and then the the X a
that's the VDA server right there and so
this is that simple simple architecture
we looked at where we've got a cloud
connector the domain controller and and
the and and the small v VA fleet now if
you want to log into this environment
that's been set up for you one thing
that you have to do is acquire some user
credentials we've pre-populated the
Active Directory domain with some sample
users and so there's a PowerShell script
in that same directory that we were in
before called get domain users
and what it will do is it will reach out
to Google cloud stores now first it's
gonna ask us which which deployment do
we want to retrieve these users for
because you can actually have multiple
of these sample deployments running in
your in your project the one we just ran
is number five here it's going to reach
out to Google Cloud storage and retrieve
an encrypted blob where we have stored
the usernames and passwords of some
sample users and then it's going to
decrypt that blob using our kms service
so we've we've stored that not in
plaintext but as as an encrypted blob
and here we can see the usernames and
passwords so let's just say we're gonna
login as user five I'm copying that
password for user five and we can bring
up the Citrix workspace and figures
crossed we should be able to say we want
to login as user underscore five at
example org
and paste that password in and that
Citrix workspace now remember this is
going to Citrix cloud through the cloud
connector against our Active Directory
domain controller we're successfully
logged in now if we go look at view all
apps we should see notepad was set up we
are authorized to use the virtual app
notepad and if we click on that that
against it's in that request to
initialize the session through our cloud
connectors or well through Citrix cloud
do the session brokering through the
cloud connector to launch the session on
the VDA here we see it's logging in and
momentarily what we should see on a
Chromebook now is a window that pops up
to let us access our Windows app which
is notepad and this environment you know
it was built again hands off took about
22 minutes or so if you run those
scripts so if you switch back to the
slides all that's out on github for you
and we invite you to check it out Google
cloud platform slash Citrix on GCP and
we we love pull requests so if you like
hacking on code if you come up some way
to improve the deployment scripts
you want to contribute back please
please you know reach out to us through
the github project alright so let's take
it home and wrap this up shall we
so one thing I hope you gathered from
this this session today is that they at
least got a taste of the fact that
citrix is about a lot more than just
virtualized apps and desktops so I'd
encourage you to come take a look at the
Citrix booth we're down on the expo
floor we're showing some kind of unique
and innovative use cases there but we
can talk to you about any of the
different services that are available
but in the booth you'll see how we've
got our Citrix workspace family of
subscriptions our Citrix networking
family and Citrix analytics and we can
give you a much better feel for how all
those things come together and provide
this thing called the secure digital
workspace so one quick call to action is
if you've got a digital transformation
project on the horizon keep us in mind
the combination of the two technologies
do a great job of taking the world that
you're living in today bridging that
into the cloud world and helping you get
there at a much higher speed and
velocity and gain the value and the
benefits back out of it I gave you some
wrap-up links here to the different
automation frameworks that we've got out
there so you know there's no reason
aside from I don't happen to have a
project that I could get into a GCP
project all you needs a GCP project and
a trial subscription to Citrix Cloud
grab that code and you can have a bunch
of fun so I pointed out the our booth
come down visit us we'll show you some
some pretty cool use cases down there
partners there's any partners in the
room I will point out that we are
actually looking for some very cloud
forward cloud first thinking types of
partners and the combination of building
a practice around Google Plus Citrix I
was a great way to differentiate your
business today
[Music]